okay as I've been telling you for weeks
now the Democratic establishment is in
panic mode over Bernie Sanders surging
and increasingly Hillary Clinton the
2016 Democratic nominee who of course
ultimately lost to Donald Trump is
attacking Bernie in exactly the ways I
said at the start of this primary will
help Trump be reelected I don't know why
she's doing it we're going to speculate
in a little bit but it is it is crushing
it is really soul-crushing to see this
happen because we know that there's only
one possible outcome to this which is it
being more likely that Donald Trump is
the next president or is re-elected to
another term Hillary Clinton is now
saying that Bernie Sanders and his
supporters didn't do enough back in 2016
to unify the Democratic Party behind
Hillary effectively blaming Bernie for
the fact that she lost to Donald Trump
now all of the normal caveats she
defeated Trump handily in the popular
vote she lost in the electoral college
there are many factors that played a
role in her losing could be that she
didn't go to key states at the end of
the election could be Russian
interference voter suppression her
likability the James Comey press
conference these are all factors we live
in a complex world we can go on and on
but after saying similar things during a
recent interview with Howard Stern late
in 2019 talking about you know Bernie
didn't do enough to help me Hillary
Clinton is now saying quote all the way
up until the end a lot of people highly
identified with his meaning Bernie's
campaign were urging people to vote
third party urging people not to vote it
had an impact so fast forward I mean you
had unfortunately a very different
outcome in the 2016 primary where I won
by four million votes I won
overwhelmingly in delegates there was no
question who was going to be the nominee
but unfortunately you know his campaign
and his principled supporters were just
very difficult and really constantly not
just attacking me but my supporters she
said this on a podcast your primary
playlist she also recently said in a new
docu-series that quote nobody likes
Bernie Sanders so let's break this down
she says it was
obvious she would be the nominee now
remember back in 2008 when Hillary ran
against Barack Obama who ultimately was
the nominee she justified continuing to
fight even when it was clear that Obama
was going to be the nominee check this
out this is Hillary saying this when it
was her up against Obama the eventual
winner rather than Bernie up against
Hillary the eventual winner and remember
I'm the person who went all the way to
the end in June in 2008 so why would I
expect anybody running against me to
give up or quit before the process is
done I don't expect that at all so first
of all there's the hypocrisy and I'm
less concerned with the hypocrisy and
more concerned with some other elements
of this a totally absent from Hillary's
analysis of 2016 is that the DNC had its
finger on the scales for Hillary Clinton
from the beginning
scheduling debates in ways that
disadvantage any would-be Challenger
which the only serious one in 2016 after
very early on was Bernie Sanders like
gee ignores that analysis completely
fine but there's a way here in which the
term unity is being wielded like a
cudgel in a really sick and self-serving
and self-destructive way when Bernie
loses he and his followers are attacked
for not putting unity over candidate
okay
now that's fair if that's true in the
sense that I think any Bernie supporter
from 2016 who voted Trump or stayed home
is part of the problem but the fact is
one in ten Bernie supporters did that in
2016 more Hillary supporters ended up
voting for McCain in 2008 when Obama was
the eventual nominee so in other words
if Bernie supporters voting for Trump or
staying home in 2016 as evidence that
Bernie did something wrong then you have
to likewise criticize Hillary and her
supporters when back in 2008 even more
of them decided to vote for McCain or
stay home rather than vote for Barack
Obama that doesn't excuse 2016 Bernie
supporters I think every
voted Hillary not Trump in 2016 look at
the situation of international
embarrassment and domestic destruction
that we have now but it's a crazy
criticism for Hillary to be making but
then the last point is this Bernie did
do a lot of events with Hillary in 2016
Bernie endorsed Hillary in 2016 Bernie
said vote Hillary in 2016 this isn't
about there are some toxic Bernie
supporters there are and there are toxic
supporters for a lot of candidates I
have someone antagonizing me who was a
big Hillary supporter named Amy Siskind
we talked about that last week but
Bernie did a lot for Hillary in 2016 and
these are not only false criticisms the
most important thing is these are
criticisms that can do nothing other
than make a Trump pre-election more
likely that's the only possible
repercussion these criticisms from
Hillary will either do nothing or they
will help Trump I don't care why Hillary
is doing this I just cared that she
stops right away why is she doing it
she might be personally upset with
Bernie she might be upset with Trump but
is taking it out on Bernie this might be
part of a larger establishment ploy to
hurt Bernie and help Biden there are
rumors that now people are talking about
what if John Kerry were to end through
the race really late I don't know
exactly what's behind this and I don't
care I just can't support an action that
will potentially help Donald Trump get
reelected and this potentially helps
Trump get reelected either by hurting
Bernie now and leaving his supporters
angry if bernie is not the nominee and
then even more of them might go and vote
for Trump or stay home or even if Bernie
is the nominee these types of attacks
hurt Bernie with the people who vote for
someone else in the primary who then
might say well you know I guess I should
probably go and vote for Bernie he's the
nominee but Hillary did say that Bernie
was mean and his supporters were mean
back in 2016 it's disastrous politics
it was completely predictable and it
absolutely has to stop let me know what
you think is behind what Hillary Clinton
is doing I have an unbeatable deal for
my viewers for just 20 bucks you can get
in
a year of award-winning antivirus plus a
VPN which makes you anonymous online you
can use them both on three of your
devices when you use the link down below
all made possible by our good friends
over at total AV they're one of our
sponsors one of the most trusted names
in computer security I use total AV
antivirus to protect my desktop computer
my phone and my laptop you're using the
internet on any device that doesn't have
an added layer of defense you're opening
yourself up to all kinds of online
threats total AV antivirus helps keep
you safe from viruses spyware ransomware
adware works on Windows Mac iOS and
Android it'll protect your computer
smartphone even your tablet all of which
are susceptible to online attacks that
can otherwise be a complete nightmare to
deal with take it from me safeguarding
yourself online from this stuff is a lot
more simple than you might realize you
just need an antivirus system like total
AV that's known for its reliability you
install it once it runs in the
background you don't even have to think
about it and the best part it's
completely affordable right now because
they're offering 80 percent off to our
audience for just 20 bucks you get total
a v's premium antivirus on three of your
devices for a whole year
and as part of that deal you'll get
totally these very dependable VPN which
makes you anonymous when you're browsing
the Internet the VPN alone is worth the
twenty bucks
check out total AV click the link right
underneath this video